محميات تتسح بوضع الاقتصادي باز فاغلب
السكان يعيشون على الصيد والصيد الاسماك
والزراعه وبيع السجائر دائره الاحصاء
الكنديه تقول ان نسبه البطاله اثنا عشر في
المئه في مسكان لهم راي اخر
نحن نساعد البطون الجائعه ياتي الينا
الناس من ثلاث محميات واحيانا ايضا من
مدينه لندن توماس اقول لهم للجائعين فقط
ممكن ان ياتي شخص يسوق مرسيدس ولكن هذا لا
يعني انه لا يستحق لان جائتكورونا اثرت
على كل الاعمال اي شخص جائع ياتي ولا اريد
دليلا فقط يقول لي انني جائع
قد لا يصدق البعض عندما يسمع ان هناك بعض
المحميات لا توجد فيها مياه صالحه للشرب
عام 2022 وفي كندا
وبدون كهرباء والناس عندما يشاهدون هذه
المناطق يشعرون بالاساء ان كندا تعامل
سكان الاصليين بهذه الطريقه
لانه كان هناك وضع خاص كان لدينا اجهزه
خاصه للتنقيه لكن الحكومه حدثت درجات
المياه النقيه وبهذا اصبح هناك اختلاف
لذلك فان المسؤولين في المحميه يكافحون من
اجل الحصول على الاموال لتحديث النظام
تحليليه المياه
المحميه التي يعيش فيها والده شبوه لا
توجد فيها مياه صالحه للشرب وهم يغلون
المياه هناك بعض المواد الكيماويه في هذه
المحميه الوضع افضل توجد فيها مياه نقيه
ولم يستطيعوا حتى الان تنضيفها